[Music]
good lord you're very beautiful you're
so tall I didn't really tell you that
tall
oh you're tall too yeah first time we're
meeting that's right I'm stunned by your
height as you know most celebrities are
very short very tiny people yeah too bad
yeah too bad you don't like that
no I think tall is beautiful yeah me too
yeah
and it's gorgeous you are you're single
at the moment are you really no
[Laughter]
something happened backstage or else you
just fell in love with you I don't know
yeah okay well legally single yeah okay
well you're are you dating sure all
right yeah okay then you're single
do you do you date would you would you
date a much smaller man does that bother
you or do you need someone to be taller
than you know I've made a shorter guys
I'm fine with it yeah yeah how tall are
you
you must be like you look like you're
well you're wearing heel yeah okay
alright okay so prep right now with the
heels you're about 6-3 6-4 oh maybe
about 6 to 63 okay do you like it I do
like it's a good thing yeah well I'm
just curious is that make it if you're a
very tall woman is it harder to to to
meet a guy are they intimidated
no it's shorter guys tend to have that
boss mentality so they'd like to you
know talk to taller women it just makes
them feel tall I don't know mm-hmm okay
what about is it important for you that
the person you date be affluent have
money or you're okay if they're they
don't know no they're gonna need their
own money now okay yeah man so they do
need to bring something to the table
they don't have to be super rich but
they do need to be financially stable
you need them to be independent I do I
can't take care of you okay living in
Los Angeles where do you live I live in
Los Angeles I can't tell you where but
I'm why can you give me a basic idea of
where you live
I didn't mean what is your address once
you said no I once I served those guys
to be financially independent I lost
interest completely
you